was it
right what I
did ask me again in 10
years try not to worry Ollie I've been
worrying about John for
years he always comes
back
the
realm do you know what the realm
is it's the Thousand Blades of aon's
enemies a story we agree to tell each
other over and over till we forget that
it's a
lie what's up ladies and gentlemen
welcome back for another Game of Thrones
video all right my friends in this video
I will show you why we may never
actually see HBO release their new
series about Jon Snow it's unfortunate
because I was very excited about the
idea of seeing what happens in Westeros
after the events of the Game of Thrones
finale well as you all know Game of
Thrones actor kid Harrington has been
developing his own show with HBO
although the network has never made
their own official announcement about
the Jon Snow show this information has
been revealed by George R Martin as well
as many other actors from the original
Game of Thrones series HBO has been
working on a number of different shows
based on George R Martin A Song of Ice
and Fire novels many of them have
already been given the green light like
House of the dragon and the new series
about Duncan egg well according to
George R Martin Mr Harrington has been
working on his own show about Jon Snow
for many years basically ever since Game
of Thrones ended not only did he have
his own showrunners but he brought his
own writers as well in fact they all Met
George R Martin at his home in Santa Fe
to discuss how they wanted to make the
show even George himself seem very
excited about this idea now before I go
any further and show you why we may
never see this show air on HBO I have to
let all of you know about this amazing
new offer I'd like to thank the sponsor
of today's video Atlas VPN as I'm sure
most of you already know all of us are
at risk on a daily basis as more and
more of our information and data goes
onto the internet what some of you may
not know is the best way to protect your
information is by the use of a VPN I
actually use mine every single day I
won't even turn on any of my devices
unless I'm already connected well this
month I've joined forces with Atlas VPN
to bring you the most affordable deal on
online protection for as little as $1.70
per month plus 6 months extra and they
also have a 30-day money back guarantee
at lless VPN not only guards your
identity but it also blocks mware and
malicious links their service will make
sure your internet searches stay private
they notify you when someone might be
trying to steal your identity and they
even give you access to online shopping
deals one of my favorite things about
Atlas VPN is that you can gain access to
content in other regions on different
streaming services like Netflix for
example if something's only available in
the UK all you have to do is change your
location to get access to it in the US
right now Atlas VPN is running a massive
black Friday discount for only $11.70
per month plus 6 months extra and don't
forget there is that 30-day money back
guarantee you don't want to miss out on
this amazing offer all you have to do is
click the link down in my description
once again I'd like to thank Atlas VPN
for sponsoring today's
video although no one has revealed the
show's outline we did get a small
glimpse about what direction they might
head in during kid Harrington's
interview at a fan convention he
basically let us know why he was
interested in developing a story about
Jon Snow's life after the events in Game
of
Thrones um my question is the fact that
your character Jon Snow he goes through
such a progression throughout the
seasons he's a ward um he goes to war so
many things happen to him um he finds
out that he is you know he's a targaryan
and then he unfortunately has to kill
Danny and then he goes you know they
throw him in jail and then he ends up
back on the wall do you ever think that
do you ever feel like your character may
have being cheated you kind of goes back
to you know the war isn't exactly the
most Country Place on
Earth I felt bad him
yeah um I think he I think if you asked
him he he would have felt he got off
lightly he you know at the end of the
show when we find him in that cell he's
preparing to be beheaded and he wants to
be he's done like the fact he goes to
the wall is the greatest gift to him and
also the greatest
curse he's going to go back up to the
place with all this history and live out
his life thinking about how he killed
Danny and live out his life thinking
about egri dying in his arms and live
out his life thinking about how he hung
Ollie and live out his life thinking
about all of this
trauma and
that that's
interesting so I think that the when we
leave him at the end of the show there's
always this feeling of like I think we
wanted some kind of little smile things
are okay he's not
okay he's not okay since HBO has never
denied these confirmations by Amelia and
George R Martin I assume they were still
working on the Jon Snow show well
according to a recent interview by HBO
CEO it now looks like Jon Snow will be
in hibernation while he's out Beyond the
Wall I actually believe this is a
mistake because as I've said before I
think this series would find more
success than House of the Dragon Every
Game of Thrones fan would want to see
what happens after Danny's death Sansa
and Bran's coronation arya's adventures
in the west as well as Jon's exit from
the Night's Watch we all know Jon would
eventually head south again for some
unknown reason resulting in him
reuniting with all of his old friends
and foes I think it would be amazing now
let's have a look at this new article so
you're able to see what HBO's CEO had to
say the headline States Game of Thrones
Jon Snow show isn't happening anytime
soon and here's why for the foreseeable
future HBO's lineup will be like
Westeros during the long summer no sign
of snow the new Game of Throne series
centered on kid Harrington's character
is nowhere near to getting an official
go-ahead from the network HBO CEO and
chairman Casey blo recently said in fact
none of the saga's other offshoots are
anywhere near ready for release we
always have game of thron scripts in
development we green lit Duncan egg in
the spring he said referring to the full
series order for a night of the Seven
Kingdoms the Hedge Knight which is based
on a game of thrones author George R
Martin's Duncan egg novelas however the
immensely popular shows other spin-offs
none of which HBO has officially
recognized we should mention have a long
night ahead of them if they ever see the
light of day I wouldn't say there is
anything else in that universe that is
close to a green light or anything HBO
CEO added but we're always working on
different ideos in
2021 he also stressed that the Game of
Thrones successor shows that would move
forward would be the ones that are the
strongest based on several measures
obviously we know George has this
Incredible Universe with all of this
really rich and complicated history and
all of these characters he old TV line
at the time so we've been trying to be
thoughtful about what are the stories
that are worth developing what would be
exciting what would the fans love he
said Duncan egg is one of those but not
the only one George R Martin made news
back in June of last year by confirming
that Harrington would revisit his Game
of Thrones role in a series about Jon
Snow AKA Aon Targaryen he said the
show's working title was snow and that
Harrington was deeply involved in the
making of it Game of Thrones star Amelia
Clark later said that he had told her
about it when she said I know it does
exist it's actually happening so we have
known about this show for well over a
year here I do wonder why HBO has never
officially made their own announcement
about it even now during this new
interview HBO CEO still doesn't mention
the Jon Snow series by name all he
really says is their main focus is on
House of the dragon and Duncan egg no
other shows will be given a green light
at least no time soon why do you think
they still haven't confirmed this
information is it because they've always
known the Jon Snow show wouldn't get
made or are they wanting it to stay a
secret for some other reason when George
R marttin made the announcement on was
not a Blog last year it really felt like
the show was moving along nicely maybe
the actors and writer strike negatively
affected its development we may never
know I hope that either HBO George R
Martin or Harrington himself will shed
some light on the situation sometime
soon I'd like to know what's actually
happening with the show for now it looks
like we won't be seeing Jon Snow or any
other original game of thrones's
character back in Westeros anytime soon
hopefully they don't forget about this
idea forever either either way I'm still
very excited to see House of the Dragon
second season as well as the new series
about Duncan egg let me know what you
think about this new information down
below as always I want to thank all of
you for watching another video I hope
all of you have a great day I will see
you again very soon
[Music]
bye